they are the dispossessed the shell
shocked the victims of war and they have
come from all over southeastern ukraine
the journey they've made is relatively
short but it has taken them days to
complete it as the russians lay siege to
their communities
but here at this supermarket no one will
harm them
alexandra and her family fled a town
over the past month sixty thousand
evacuees have been registered here in
zapposia
many have traveled from the ruins of
mariopol in anything they could find
a journey made by pechava and her
daughter christina
pichava's husband died in mario pole
trying to fetch some water
there may be 100 000 people still
trapped in that beleaguered city but the
people trying to get them out are not
professionals they're volunteers
[Music]
more organized attempts are being made
now to to send buses directly into mario
paul but for the most part this is how
people are making their escape in a
assortment of cars trucks and vans
driven by extremely brave individuals
mariat zimmerman has a van and an
extraordinary sense of duty
she led a column of vehicles into the
center of mario paul because she used to
live there and she knows what they're
going through maria did you drive into
mariopole
yes
that was very brave
yes but it's not the first time
did you have a an agreement with with
the russian military
technology
many were filled with gratitude
maria avoided the shelling and the land
mines too and she expected nothing in
return
the local government has assisted with
this ad hoc evacuation sending buses to
the russian occupied city of bergensk
more than 2 000 were assisted here
but attempts by the red cross to
organize large-scale convoys have failed
due to security concerns
the size of this challenge is difficult
to grasp more than 10 million people
have been displaced in ukraine and there
are many more who are still seeking
sanctuary
john sparks sky news in zapposia